primera cita electoral del año en
colombia casi 39 millones de electores
colombianos están llamados a las urnas
pero que se elige este domingo lo
primero es la renovación del congreso de
la república para ello se vota a los
integrantes del senado compuesto por 108
miembros repartidos de la siguiente
manera 100 senadores por circunscripción
nacional 5 escaños para el partido de
las guerrilla de las farc comunes 2
escaños especiales para las comunidades
indígenas y un escaño adicional que se
asignará luego de las elecciones
presidenciales al candidato a la
presidencia que ocupa el segundo lugar
en los comicios y la cámara de
representantes con 188 miembros
repartidos en 161 escaños ordinarios 5
para el partido comunes 4 curules
especiales 2 para las comunidades afro 1
para las indígenas y 1 para colombianos
residentes en el exterior un candidato
raizal un escaño para la fórmula
vicepresidencial del candidato en
segundo lugar y 16 curules especiales de
paz para las víctimas del conflicto
estos últimos son una novedad fruto de
los acuerdos de paz de 2016 y podrán
votar los ciudadanos de los 167
municipios golpeados por la guerra
interna el paco que firmó las farc y el
gobierno en su momento establece una
sobrerrepresentación de ciertas regiones
para permitirles a ellos tener una voz
más clara en el sistema para manifestar
sus descontentos y también para lograr
la implementación del proceso de paz la
jornada electoral también marca el
inicio de la batalla por la presidencia
que se votará en primera vuelta el
próximo 29 de mayo los colombianos
podrán votar si así lo desean por sus
candidatos presidenciales de las 3
grandes coaliciones de centro izquierda
y derecha todos dicen que quieren
arreglar el país pero a la final nunca
terminamos en nada entonces pues ojalá
este cambio sea de verdad unos comicios
que llegan después de dos años marcados
por la pandemia el incremento de las
desigualdades el estallido social con el
paro nacional y el recrudecimiento de la
violencia a los territorios lo que
marcarán los retos políticos del país